Computer systems bring together many technologies
and harness them to provide fast execution
of programs.
Some of these technologies are relatively
new, others have been with us for decades.
Each of the system components comes with a
detailed specification of their functionality
and interface.
The expectation is that system designers can
engineer the system based on the component
specifications without having to know the
details of the implementations of each component.
This is good since many of the underlying
technologies change, often in ways that allow
the components to become smaller, faster,
cheaper, more energy efficient, and so on.
Assuming the new components still implement
same interfaces, they can be integrated into
the system with very little effort.
The moral of this story is that the important
part of the system architecture is the interfaces.
Our goal is to design interface specifications
that can survive many generations of technological
change.
One approach to long-term survival is to base
the specification on a useful abstraction
that hides most, if not all, of the low-level
implementation details.
Operating systems provide many interfaces
that have remained stable for many years.
For example, network interfaces that reliably
deliver streams of bytes to named hosts, hiding
the details of packets, sockets, error detection
and recovery, etc.
Or windowing and graphics systems that render
complex images, shielding the application
from details about the underlying graphics
engine.
Or journaled file systems that behind-the-scenes
defend against corruption in the secondary
storage arrays.
Basically, we're long since past the point
where we can afford to start from scratch
each time the integrated circuit gurus are
able to double the number of transistors on
a chip,
or the communication wizards figure out how
to go from 1GHz networks to 10GHz networks,
or the memory mavens are able to increase
the size of main memory by a factor of 4.
The interfaces that insulate us from technological
change are critical to ensure that improved
technology isn't a constant source of disruption.
There are some famous examples of where an
apparently convenient choice of interface
has had embarrassing long-term consequences.
For example, back in the days of stand-alone
computing, different ISAs made different choices
on how to store multi-byte numeric values
in main memory.
IBM architectures store the most-significant
byte in the lowest address (so called "big
endian"), while Intel's x86 architectures
store the least-significant byte first (so
called "little endian").
But this leads to all sorts of complications
in a networked world where numeric data is
often transferred from system to system.
This is a prime example of a locally-optimal
choice having an unfortunate global impact.
As the phrase goes: "a moment of convenience,
a lifetime of regret."
Another example is the system-level communication
strategy chosen for the first IBM PC, the
original personal computer based Intel CPU
chips.
IBM built their expansion bus for adding I/O
peripherals, memory cards, etc., by simply
using the interface signals provided by then-current
x86 CPU.
So the width of the data bus, the number of
address pins, the data-transfer protocol,
etc. where are exactly as designed for interfacing
to that particular CPU.
A logical choice since it got the job done
while keeping costs as low a possible.
But that choice quickly proved unfortunate
as newer, higher-performance CPUs were introduced,
capable of addressing more memory or providing
32-bit instead of 16-bit external data paths.
So system architects were forced into offering
customers the Hobson's choice of crippling
system throughput for the sake of backward
compatibility,
or discarding the networking card they bought
last year since it was now incompatible with
this year's system.
But there are success stories too.
The System/360 interfaces chosen by IBM in
the early 1960s carried over to the System/370
in the 70's and 80's and to the Enterprise
System Architecture/390 of the 90's.
Customers had the expectation that software
written for the earlier machines would continue
to work on the newer systems and IBM was able
to fulfill that expectation.
Maybe the most notable long-term interface
success is the design the TCP and IP network
protocols in the early 70's, which formed
the basis for most packet-based network communication.
A recent refresh expanded the network addresses
from 32 to 128 bits, but that was largely
invisible to applications using the network.
It was a remarkably prescient set of engineering
choices that stood the test of time for over
four decades of exponential growth in network
connectivity.
Today's lecture topic is figuring out the
appropriate interface choices for interconnecting
system components.
In the earliest systems these connections
were very ad hoc in the sense that the protocols
and physical implementation were chosen independently
for each connection that had to be made.
The cable connecting the CPU box to the memory
box (yes, in those days, they lived in separate
19" racks!) was different than the cable connecting
the CPU to the disk.
Improving circuit technologies allowed system
components to shrink from cabinet-size to
board-size
and system engineers designed a modular packaging
scheme that allowed users to mix-and-match
board types that plugged into a communication
backplane.
The protocols and signals on the backplane
reflected the different choices made by each
vendor - IBM boards didn't plug into Digital
Equipment backplanes, and vice versa.
This evolved into some standardized communication
backplanes that allowed users to do their
own system integration, choosing different
vendors for their CPU, memory, networking,
etc.
Healthy competition quickly brought prices
down and drove innovation.
However this promising development was overtaken
by rapidly improving performance, which required
communication bandwidths that simply could
not be supported across a multi-board backplane.
These demands for higher performance and the
ability to integrate many different communication
channels into a single chip, lead to a proliferation
of different channels.
In many ways, the system architecture was
reminiscent of the original systems - ad-hoc
purpose-built communication channels specialized
to a specific task.
As we'll see, engineering considerations have
led to the widespread adoption of general-purpose
unidirectional point-to-point communication
channels.
There are still several types of channels
depending on the required performance, the
distance travelled, etc.,
but asynchronous point-to-point channels have
mostly replaced the synchronous multi-signal
channels of earlier systems.
Most system-level communications involve signaling
over wires, so next we'll look into some the
engineering issues we've had to deal with
as communication speeds have increased from
kHz to GHz.